όταν τελειώσει αυτή δεντα τιμια ερωότηση την οποία για να μερα πολύ τα ελικριμής δεν
την εσκεφτικά γιο να να να εξηγήσω ηατιγια πάρα πολλά χρόνια στη στη ζωήμα με
άχονε το αύριο η επόμενη μέρα έφερεντα ο θεώς και φέρνηται ο θεως και βασικό
βασική ετσι αρχή και ο βασικός τρόπος με τον οποίο πο ρεύκουμε κάθε μέρα είναι
να κάμνω ότι καλήτερο εκίνεται είναι στρατιώτης για τον τον τόπο έτσι θωρό των έαυτό
έχω υποχρέωση σήμέρα αβαίναντης τους γεοργούς μου θα κάμω το καλύπτερο θα ξεπεράσω τις δυνανατότητες
μου ότι είναι ανθρωποίνω δυνατόν και περνά σταερκαμου θέλω να το κάμνο για το καλόν
τούτο του τόπου τούτον πορεύκουμε κάθε μέρα και η επόμενη μέρα έχιο θεώς για ούλλους
και δαξι είναι κάτι που ένθελω να το σκέφτουμε ενα έχω αντζέντες για την επόμενη
μέρα διαφέριμε να κάμνω το καλύπτερον που κάμνο σήμερα χωρίς να σημαίνει το ότι δουλεύκω
εφήμέρα να τού τον που ενο δουλεύκω για να αφήσω κάτι πίσο μου και τού
των εντο σημαντικό για να μπορέσει και επόμενος ται μεθυμεπόμενος να πατήσει πάνω να πάμε
να κόμα το ψηλα σεκάθωχαριστώ πολα σητασεκαλά κιες και φίλαάνατα αλλά ετορκάε τάι στο τέλος
του καλάνα τηαχοενε τόμ